das war aber was war es eigentlich
spielplanänderungen begonnen hat es als
serie im feuilleton der faz wo
vergessene stücke vorgestellt worden
daraus ist ein buch entstanden eine
anthologie beim tropen verlag und dann
entwickelt sich die idee aus diesem
historischen material heraus kurzfilme
für die gegenwart zu drehen an
unterschiedlichen locations mit
interessanten unkonventionellen
gesprächspartnerinnen zu behaupten dass
diese vergessene stücke wirklich etwas
bedeuten können für unsere gegenwart
es sollte eine lange nacht der
vergessene stücke geben in der berliner
volksbühne
das hat nicht funktioniert gegen korona
aber wir haben eine art von video
dokumentation dieser veranstaltung
trotzdem auf die beine gestellt und
somit theater nach hause gebracht in der
zeit des logins corona höhepunkt haben
wir auf der faz seite theater möglich
gemacht und jetzt der sommer die theater
öffnen wieder es gibt hoffnung langsam
wird wieder gespielt ein ganzes jahr
lang verhinderte spiellust bricht sich
bahn und so haben wir uns entschieden
noch eine zweite und letzte staffel
spiel kann änderungen anzuschließen wir
haben dieses thema später änderung also
ausgesagt hier eine eierlegende
wollmilchsau und haben uns sehr gefreut
über das interesse und die verschiedenen
anregungen die gekommen sind und hoffen
dass das jetzt in einer weise zu einem
zu einer diskussion führt über das was
spielplanänderungen bedeuten könnte wir
wollen jetzt kurz rückschau halten auf
höhepunkte auf dieses lustige momente
auf das was spielplanänderungen gewesen
ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also mein highlight war auf jeden fall
mit debra feldmann durch die sonnenallee
zu laufen und von ihr in so eine
verlorene welt des jüdischen theaters
eingeführt zu werden in dem buch ist
quasi und das ist mein heutiges modernes
verständnis davon in dieburg ist eine
seele die sich dem schicksal nicht fügt
die sich gott nicht fühlt und auch ein
highlight war mit carl hegemann dem
dramaturgen jahre lang an der volksbühne
in dem restaurant golisch zu sitzen und
zu schlemmen wir haben schnitzel und
spargel und weißwein getrunken und haben
uns über dieses stück unterhalten und er
war eigentlich nicht zu stoppen er hat
keinen punkt und komma gemacht weil das
eine unglaubliche begeisterung für das
stück seiner paar von lord byron hat und
das war für mich auch ein ganz
besonderer moment der mir so lustig in
erinnerung bleibt
es ist die frage ob es überhaupt einer
will das nicht völlig anachronistisch
ist zu sagen man interessiert sich für
eine gegenmeinung und sagen man ist
offen für jemand der ganz anders denkt
vielleicht wird es deshalb nicht
gespielt weil keiner ist offen dafür
er will auch dass zeugen dass man das
ist vielleicht gut ist mein highlight
war das gespräch mit der drag queen nina
queer über das stück gabriel von george
sand was sie sehr sehr ausgiebig
analysiert und bearbeitet hat und ja
eben darüber mit mir gesprochen hat wie
diese ganzen thematiken von qs das
schauspiel der geschlechter sex drugs
und rock'n roll schon vor 200 jahren
eine rolle gespielt haben und eben immer
der gleiche scheiß gewesen sind wie
heute ich wusste schon ganz am anfang
ich brauchte eigentlich gar nicht zuende
leser ich wusste genau worauf es
hinausläuft weil diese geschichte auch
so ähnlich meiner ist und man sieht es
spielt den ganz anderen jahrhunderten es
ist immer noch der gleiche scheiße
ein weiteres highlight bei dem stück war
das gespräch mit der jungen regisseurin
laura lotz die am gabriel als magischen
sinne als
ja im an zitationen stück der arbeiter
bewegung interpretiert hat und eine
performance daraus machen beute mit rote
armee soldaten panzern die auf die bühne
fahren soldaten den dreck und beyoncé
musik letzten endes finde ich den stoff
ziemlich einzigartig und gerade deswegen
umso wichtiger ihnen auf die bühne zu
bringen oder vielleicht überhaupt mal
ins deutsche zu übersetzen
meine zwei höhepunkte waren einmal der
boxtrainer der inspiriert von glaube und
heimat dem stück von karl schönherr über
gewaltprävention bei jugendlichen
geredet hat und in einer solchen
dringlichkeit und sprache dass man das
gefühl hatte dass dieses stück
eigentlich auch dazu dienen könnte
gewaltprävention zu üben wir wissen auch
wenn sie das auf der straße umsetzung
sind sie hier raus genau der andere
höhepunkt war der gasreinigung mit dem
ich über das fenster als motiv
gesprochen habe und der während dieses
gesprächs habe einmal das fenster so
ansprach als wäre es ein lebendiger
gegenstand die verschiedenen seiten
benannte die blaue seite die staub seite
und mit seinen worten entstand auf
einmal so etwas wie eine beziehung zu
diesem von uns allen hundertmal am tag
betrachteten und benutzten gegenstand
auf einer wurde dieser gegenstand sehr
sehr wertvoll da durch das ja so
ansprach und damit hat er eigentlich das
was er allerdings stück auch gewollt hat
umgesetzt
das ist deswegen ein initial stück der
moderne weil es den gegenstand fenster
so ernst und zur hauptrolle erklärt und
ihm eben ein eigenleben zugesteht in
dieser hinsicht spielplan änderung in
der wirklichkeit ich hatte mal ein kunde
näherte 17 jahren die stiefel zu lassen
und war auch nicht so einig
in einer zeit wo die theater zum zentrum
der debatte um mehr diversität und
veränderungen werden wollten wir den
punkt machen dass man diese debatte auch
auf dem kanon ausweiten muss das klingt
jetzt erst mal noch einen ganz netten
idee die niemanden weh tut aber wenn man
das ernst nimmt dann hat das auch viel
mit denkmalsturz zu tun
dann heißt das nämlich weniger brecht
mehr allgemeiner mehr maurice
maeterlinck meer lord byron manager
storm erklärte hacks und männer
das wetter war der dackel mehr salomon
ans die und mehr marieluise fleißer
immer die spielplan änderung also ernst
nimmt dann bleibt er diese brecht ganz
schön alleine sitzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]